WHEN I WAS A LITTLE GIRL,
MY MOTHER TOOK ME
TO SEE ONE OF HER
FAVORITE FILMS.
FELLINI'S "LA STRADA"
I WAS A LITTLE YOUNG TO READ
SUBTITLES, BUT NONETHELESS
SHE'S AN ACTOR, AND SHE
WANTED TO SHARE WITH ME
ONE OF THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARY PERFORMANCES
THAT OF GIULIETTA MASINA.
HER PERFORMANCE, AND THAT
FILM, WERE FILLED WITH MAGIC AND
HEARTBREAK, AND TRUTH.
AND IT WAS NOT THE WORDS,
BUT THE LANGUAGE OF
CINEMA ITSELF THAT
TRANSFORMED ME FOREVER.
I ALSO LEARNED THAT "LA STRADA"
WAS THE FIRST FILM TO WIN
THE OSCAR IN THIS
NEXT CATEGORY.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR BEST
INTERNATIONAL FEATURE FILM.
FROM DENMARK,
"ANOTHER ROUND."
DIRECTED BY
THOMAS VINTERBERG.
FROM HONG KONG,
"BETTER DAYS."
DIRECTED BY
DEREK KWOK-CHEUNG TSANG.
FROM ROMANIA, "COLLECTIVE."
DIRECTED BY
ALEXANDER NANAU.
FROM TUNISIA, "THE MAN
WHO SOLD HIS SKIN."
DIRECTED BY
KAOUTHER BEN HANIA.
FROM BOSNIA AND HERZEGOVINA,
"QUO VADIS, AIDA?"
DIRECTED BY
JASMILA ZBANIC.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
"ANOTHER ROUND," DENMARK
DIRECTED BY
THOMAS VINTERBERG
[ APPLAUSE ]
HEY, WOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS TO THE ACADEMY
FOR VOTIING ON THIS FILM.
THIS IS BEYOND ANYTHING I COULD
EVER IMAGINE, EXCEPT THIS IS
SOMETHING I'VE ALWAYS IMAGINED
SINCE I WAS 5 OR SOMETHING.
I'VE BEEN PREPARING SPEECHES
IN TRAIN STATIONS, AT SCHOOL,
IN THE TOILET.
AND HERE I AM, IT'S REAL.
IT'S AMAZING.
WOW. THIS IS A FILM
ABOUT LETTING GO
OF CONTROL IN LIFE, AND AS I
LOST CONTROL IN MY OWN.
AND I WANT TO THANK MY WIFE,
HELENE, WHO SITS OVER HERE, FOR
BEING THE ANGEL OF THIS PROJECT.
FOR GUIDING ME THROUGH THIS VERY
DIFFICULT PERIOD.
I WANT TO THANK MY CHILDREN,
MY FAMILY, NANNA, IDA, ALBERT, LILY.
MY SCREENWRITER,
TOBIAS LINDHOLM.
WHO IS MY GUARDIAN ANGEL
IN BOTH LIVING AND WRITING.
I'M SENDING YOU MY PRAISES.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE TO
THANK, BUT I'LL GET THERE.
I'M SENDING MY PRAISES TO
ZENTROPA, SISSE, KASPER, PETER,
KORNUM, ALL OF YOU.
YOU HAD SO MUCH HEART AND
STRENGTH AT THE SAME TIME.
THE CREW, WHO THREW EVERYTHING
THEY HAD IN THEIR HANDS,
TO RESCUE ME,
AND RESCUE THIS FILM.
THE INVESTORS, MY AGENTS,
DISTRIBUTORS, SAMUEL GOLDWYN
BART WALKER, ALL OF YOU,
CHRISTINA BAZDEKIS, JESSICA SYKES,
BUMBLE. YOU'RE ALL THERE.
CINETIC, THANK YOU FOR SHOWING THE
BRAVERY OF INVESTING IN A MOVIE
THAT IS ABOUT FOUR DEPRAVED,
WHITE, DRUNK MEN, BASICALLY.
WHO TEACHES CHILDREN
TO DRINK AS WELL.
I MEAN, PRETTY UPHILL,
IN MY PERSPECTIVE.
THOSE FOUR WHITE MEN BEING
MAGNUS MILLANG, LARS RANTHE,
THOMAS BO LARSEN, MY OLD FRIEND.
THE WHOLE CAST, YOU WERE BRILLIANT.
SUSAN, MARIA, ALL OF YOU, TOOK
OUT YOUR HEARTS FOR THIS
AND WERE BRILLIANT.
I WANT TO SEND A SPECIAL
THANKS, OF COURSE,
TO MADS MIKKELSON.
YEAH, GIVE HIM A HAND.
[ APPLAUSE ]
MADS, YOU GAVE US YOUR FINEST.
NOT JUST FOR THE FILM, BUT FOR
MY DAUGHTER AS WELL.
AND I'LL NEVER FORGET IT.
WHOO, OKAY.
SO, WE WANTED TO MAKE
A FILM THAT CELEBRATES LIFE
AND FOUR DAYS INTO SHOOTING,
THE IMPOSSIBLE HAPPENED.
AN ACCIDENT ON A HIGHWAY
TOOK MY DAUGHTER AWAY.
SOMEONE LOOKING INTO
A CELL PHONE.
AND WE MISS HER, AND I LOVE HER
AND -- SORRY.
TWO MONTHS BEFORE
WE SHOT THIS MOVIE,
AND TWO MONTHS
BEFORE SHE DIED,
SHE WAS IN AFRICA.
SHE SENT ME A LETTER,
AND SHE JUST READ
THE SCRIPT, AND SHE WAS
GLOWING WITH EXCITEMENT.
SHE LOVED THIS
AND SHE FELT SEEN BY THIS
AND SHE WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE IN THIS
AND IF ANYONE DARES TO BELIEVE
THAT SHE'S HERE WITH US SOMEHOW,
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SEE HER
CLAPPING AND CHEERING WITH US.
WE ENDED UP MAKING THIS MOVIE
FOR HER, AS HER MONUMENT.
SO, IDA, THIS IS A MIRACLE THAT
JUST HAPPENED, AND YOU'RE A PART
OF THIS MIRACLE.
MAYBE YOU'VE BEEN PULLING SOME
STRINGS SOMEWHERE, I DON'T KNOW.
BUT THIS ONE IS FOR YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.